ciao benvenuti in un nuovissimo oggi
parliamo di calcio in particolare delle
ragazze il calcio sì perché noi ragazzi
insomma ci dividiamo tra chi lo ama e
chi lo odia chi è bravissima a giocare a
calcio e chi è proprio negata ecco ho
deciso di raggruppare tutte queste
tipologie in un video buona visione
e da tanto che non gioco è il mio avviso
proviamo a fare il tifo
no no non mi sono fatto niente o cosa
stai facendo
ecco la faccia amici ai parenti agli
amici ma ce la fai da te fondamentale
lira ma è troppo bravo per biondo la
partita lascia la partita non puoi farlo
ha preso la palla con le mani amorevoli
del portiere lui può ultimi ha deciso e
cosa che sento mia la solita coloni e
l'altra squadra quindi non meno marina
si chiama sostituzione è però però con
gli ha la maglietta in alto colore scusi
perché lui può e gli altri alla maglia
uguale amore ma quando finisce siamo al
23esimo ancora la 22 minuti ei suoi
finora vinciamo
finisce il primo tempo e poi e poi altri
45 questa squadra
p no vabbè ma stiamo scherzando
addormentano arrivare tutti e lui lo fa
di sicuro
mamma sì stiamo dando alla partita
guardare la partita ha detto che arrivò
non abbiamo nov abbiamo ma quanto è
buono il 4 a me aver usato il 10 di vino
lì con le braccia
vabbè ma non dice che colpaccio a cioè
che caldo ma va bene è sposato con
successo dai no e stato veramente quello
ma quelle single
praticamente ribaltiamo subito cosa
abbiamo detto è chi vinceva di vincere
sportivo quelli che sanno perdere ma
siamo i migliori non c'è per nessuno per
nessuno cioè adesso spiegatemi cosa c'è
di bello vedere i 25 c che corrono
dietro una palla ma qui pagati per fare
cosa ma guarda veramente e l'erba
lei è battuta con l'erba felpe statali
inutilmente cioè perché perché perché
siamo ora questa roba
cioè io odio il calcio andiamo
ci siano ci siamo sta per arrivare e
andiamo bene che c'è da guardare non ha
mai visto una ragazza giocare a calcio è
così purtroppo arrivati alla fine del
video vi raccomando se il video vi è
piaciuto lasciatemi un like e commentate
qui sotto con o queste mozy o collage
tag primo straining e soprattutto fatemi
sapere a quale di queste tipologie
appartenete voi se anche voi volete la
porta che ho utilizzato nel video vi
basterà comprare tre tubi di pringles
avere inter iniziativa cliccare sul sito
che vi lascio questo indiscrezione e
seguire le istruzioni per partecipare
anche voi al primo strani se la prima
volta che vedete un mio video mi
raccomando iscrivetevi al canale e
cliccate sulla campanella ritrovate
vicino al tasso d'iscrizione per
rimanere sempre aggiornati su tutti i
miei video e soprattutto per essere i
primi a commentare
ultima cosa ma non per importanza
seguitemi su tutti i social instagram
facebook e music hall mimando macedone
ci vediamo al prossimo video ciao
[Musica]